Ja ihr habt es sicher mitbekommen obwohl der hurricanes auf die niedrigste stufe herabgesetzt wurde waren seine
auswirkungen dramatisch und es gibt mehrere gründe die florence so besonders gefährlich gemacht haben welcher sind und was die globale erderwärmung
damit zu tun hat das alles und noch viel mehr jetzt bei bigsim science fiction herzlich willkommen
Zuletzt hatten die us-behörden florence zwar noch
herabgestuft doch die gefahr ist noch lange nicht gebannt extreme sturmfluten und
regen bender die sich tagelang über dem land ergießen werden der deutsche astronaut alexander gerst hat von der raumstation iss
wirklich krasse fotos vom voraus gemacht dazu seine eindringliche warnung per twitter an die usa
watch out amerika also sowas wie aufgepasst amerika und es gibt tatsächlich einige aspekte die diesen hurrikan zu einem
ungewöhnlichen sturm gemacht haben und zu einer tödlichen gefahr außerdem 17 menschen sind gestorben und ganze ortschaften
werden wohl noch in der folge
ausradiert dennoch immer
bahn sich das wasser seinen weg ins landesinnere und das hat vor allem mit dem klimawandel zu tun zum einen hat der florence die möglichkeit
nahe der küste noch einmal so richtig aufzuladen den hurricanes bekommen ihre energie aus dem warmen ozean der mindestens
27 grad celsius warm ist derzeit ist das wasser an der küste an die
30 grad warm dass es mehr als normalerweise um diese zeit das hat florence noch einmal so richtig gepusht dazu kommt er bringt
gigantische regenmengen mit sich durch den klimawandel
sind es laut aktuellen analysen 50 prozent mehr regen und der niederschlag den hurricanes mit sich bringen stellt sich meist noch einmal als viel
dramatischer heraus als der wind selbst das haben wir auch 2017 bhw gesehen der houston unter wasser gesetzt hat der
flüsse treten über die ufer wasser und schlamm
strömen dann die hügel herab an den bergen der us-ostküste ist viel feuchtigkeit ab geregnet unmengen an wasser in form von sturzfluten
suchen sogar das landesinnere ein gemälde zum beispiel die ortschaft feiert will land unter und sie ist
150 kilometer von der küste entfernt und
die tatsache dass es in vielen regionen der ostküste schon in der letzten zeit sehr viel geregnet hat macht das nicht besser im gegenteil
denn der grundwasserspiegel ist hoch und böden sowieso schon sehr nass das führt dazu dass das regenwasser nicht im boden versickern kann
was die überschwemmung
verstärkt schon alexander gerst hat er festgestellt dass es sich bei florence um einen sehr großen jährigen handelt der den regen wohl über eine
ungewöhnlich große region bringen wird sein durchmesser lag bei etwa 800 kilometern fachleute
warnen deswegen vor überschwemmungen in fast allen regionen von south und north carolina
das ist insgesamt ein gebiet das größer ist als großbritannien und der hurrikan ist nicht nur groß sondern auch langsam seine geringe geschwindigkeit hat zweierlei
auswirkungen zum einen hat der länger feuchtigkeit aus dem meer aufs land gebracht und zum anderen ist er auch über einen längeren zeitraum
ab geregnet und auch das ist eine folge des klimawandels wie ein forschungsteam in einer analyse im fachmagazin nature
festgehalten hat besonders große sorge bereitet den menschen in north carolina
übrigens die tierhaltung industrie auf den punkt gebracht lautet die große frage wohin mit der ganzen schweine scheiße
denn mehr als
2000 fahren produzieren eine gigantische menge an gülle die lediglich in offenen gruben gelagert wird durch die überschwemmungen könnten krankheitserreger
so sogar ins grundwasser gelangen und das trinkwasser
verseuchen ganz abgesehen davon dass die fäkalien mit großer sicherheit früher oder später in flüsse seen und
ins meer gelangen dabei steht schon länger fest dass diese region enorm vom klimawandel betroffen ist 2011 kam eine kommission zu dem ergebnis
dass der meeresspiegel an der küste north carolinas um einen meter steigen könnte und das bis zum ende des 21 jahrhunderts
derzeit sind es knapp ist es knapp 1 cm pro jahr und das nur am rande
klimaforscher melden sich angesichts der aktuellen situation zu wort und warnen vor einer weiteren
globalen katastrophe so wie etwa der wissenschaftler stefan rahmstorf aus potsdam
zitat die globale erwärmung hat auswirkungen auf tropische stürme und das maß der von ihnen
verursachten schäden heißt also im klartext die intensität solcher stürme könnte durch wärmere
meerestemperaturen weiter steigen
und wir machen weiter hierbei klicks um ihr können tricks und jetzt weiter werbefrei machen wir haben schon angefangen ab sofort gibt es jeden
hat ein video ohne prolls dank eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung
abwehr wird also mitglied hier unter dem video draufklicken und ihr bekommt noch exklusive extra videos live streams und noch ein paar weitere
privilegien wenn er immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann hättet mich übrigens bei whatsapp dann bekommt ihr den link zum video vor allen andern von mir
persönlich auf euer handy einfach hier draufklicken und da drunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken klimawandel bestätigt skeptiker
endgültig widerlegt bis dann
bleibt dran